sur le L le le
L Beaucoup de gens en général
[Musique]
demandent euh une fois que j'ai découvert le Salvador et que
j'ai réalisé qu'ils avaient adopté
le le président Kelly avait adopté le
bitco pour la nation, c'était
automatiquement sur mon radar au  l'endroit
où je veux être, c'est quelque chose que
j'avais prévu il y a 10 ans et j'ai
dit aux gens qu'un jour un État-nation
adopterait Bitcoin et ils pensaient que j'étais
fou et puis voilà, je n'ai
même jamais entendu parler du Salvador mais je je
J'ai entendu parler du nouveau
président de Bitcoin et de ses projets, euh
non seulement d'adopter Bitcoin, mais euh de développer un
peu de monnaie
[Musique]
Ville
Je crois que ça va arriver donc
je reste, je ne suis pas concerné  tu
sais que je regarde, je regarderai
partout ailleurs mais ici ça va
[Musique]
arriver, c'est très
beau comme en ce moment, ça peut être
stupide de vendre le Bitcoin pour lequel tu peux aller
[Musique]
fam